19:56 in egypt has just nationalized the
Suez Canal the canal had previously been
owned by the Suez Canal Company which
was controlled mostly by France in
Britain the seizure was ordered by the
Egyptian President Gamal Abdel Nasser
who wanted to use the proceeds from the
tolls that can now generated for
infrastructure projects in Egypt so
Egypt was a non-aligned country during
the Cold War and NASA wished to maintain
good relations with both the USA in the
USSR NASA's only real aim was to
maintain the independence of the Arab
world and to prevent any imperial powers
old or new from dominating it again
America was unhappy with NASA's like a
hostility to the Soviet Union and so
along with Britain withdrew previously
promised financial assistance to Egypt
as a result NASA declared his intention
to nationalize the Suez Canal to make up
for the lost cash the French and British
governments were furious and saw the
nationalization as an attack on their
influence in the region so Israel led by
Prime Minister David ben-gurion was also
upset with the nationalization Cissna
sir immediately banned all Israeli
shipping from the canal
soon after the French under Prime
Minister guy Malay invited the British
led by Prime Minister Anthony Eden and
the Israelis to bring the situation
under control the plan was for Israel to
capture the Sinai Peninsula and that
Britain and France would then capture
the Suez Canal under the pretext of
restoring order to the region on October
the 29th Israeli forces invaded the
peninsula and the next day Britain of
France delivered an ultimatum to both
Egypt and Israel both sides were ordered
to withdraw 10 miles from the Suez Canal
or they would intervene one problem is
rales troops were still 40 miles from
the canal this gave Britain and France
his part in the plan away and both were
met with international condemnation
specifically from the Americans who were
furious that they hadn't been consulted
by their allies on November the 5th
British and French paratroopers were
dropped into the area around the canal
to secure it so the Egyptian army wasn't
really prepared to resist the well-armed
and well-trained militaries of the three
nations attacking him and they were
quickly overrun however the population
of Egypt rallied around nasara many
civilians took to resisting the invaders
even passively or even taking up arms
themselves the military side of the
conflict was over quickly with Israel
France and the UK achieving their
objectives
politically though it was a nightmare
for them most nations across the world
sided with Egypt and the USSR even
threatened to use nuclear weapons
against Britain and France
Dwight D Eisenhower the US president was
absolutely livid with the British and
French and even went so far as to
threaten to kick them both out of NATO
furthermore Eisenhower threatened to
sell-off sterling bonds which would have
severely harmed the value of
pound which in turn would have likely
crashed the British economy as a result
Britain immediately ceased hostilities
in France and Israel une after signed a
ceasefire British and French forces left
Egypt in late November and his road
didn't withdraw from the Sinai
peninsular until March of the next year
the Suez Crisis was over for Britain the
Suez Crisis was a disaster and
demonstrated that it could no longer
pursue its own foreign policy without
the consent of the United States the
crisis would also end the career of
Anthony Eden for France the effects were
similar and Malay wouldn't last much
longer than Eden for Israel the war was
much more profitable his Rao's
capabilities were now demonstrated to
its neighbors and whilst Israel still
couldn't use the Suez Canal it could now
use the straight tooth to run which
Egypt had previously broke Aidid since
1950 the crisis also saw the expansion
of the UN's duties and importance in
international diplomacy the crisis of
the UN send an international force of
peacekeepers the first of its kind to
the region to calm and monitor the
situation as for Egypt a more
specifically NASA the crisis was an
unparalleled victory NASA was now seen
as the Arab world's defender against
colonial aggressors and his popularity
soared this in turn would see him become
the face of the pan-arab East movement
which would briefly see the unification
of Egypt of Syria but that's a story for
a different time I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching a
special thanks to James Bissonnette
ozark a flash Henry Robin Winston Cawood
Adam Harvey and Skye Chappell
you